human error may be to blame for the loss
of thousands of embryos and eggs at a
fertility clinic outside Cleveland
Hospital officials publicly admitted
yesterday that the number of eggs and
embryos lost when the freezer system
failed is actually double original
estimates in a Werner is following this
story in a good morning good morning
well University Hospital says an alarm
system that had been malfunctioning for
weeks was shut off on March 3rd and
failed to notify staff when the storage
tanks temperature began to rise now some
950 families have learned they are the
victims of what the hospital is calling
a catastrophic failure I assumed they
were in the safest place amber and
Elliot ash had hoped their two-year-old
son Ethan would one day have a sibling
we want to move on and get past this but
we keep being reminded that that we did
lose our our only chance is there now
the Ash family is suing University
Hospitals and calling for new
regulations in the fertility industry we
had a terrible situation at our
fertility clinic University Hospitals
CEO Tom's NT notified families in a
facebook video and sent this letter of
apology saying it was unlikely any eggs
or embryos are viable because the remote
alarm system on the tank designed to
alert a u.h employee to changes like
temperature swings was off I don't
understand how somebody could be so
truly reckless the hospital said some of
the eggs and embryos had been stored
there since the 1980s and the tank in
question needed preventative maintenance
which was being performed while the
investigation is ongoing human error has
not been ruled out we are in the process
of identifying the exact sequence of
when this occurred and when who ordered
the deactivation
James Lew is chairman of obstetrics and
gynecology at University Hospitals and
said the hospital takes full
responsibility we are very sorry that
this happened but for the Ashe family
it's hard to understand why the tank was
not adequately monitored everybody just
wants you H to be accountable and to be
transparent and nobody wants to see
failures like this occur elsewhere
University Hospitals says their
fertility clinic continues to operate
and they're now using new storage tanks
and alarm systems the hospital is
refunding the storage fees for these
families and waving future fees for
seven years but of course you can't get
it back for these that's what I was
thinking - anything we keep hearing how
rare it is you know but yet we've had
two cases two or three or three
different places different cities around
the country with different fertility
clinics so there's a problem yeah all
right Anna Werner thanks Anna